shout out to our boy hans kim because
hans kim went up and fought him a
[ __ ] arena this kid's been
he was homeless two years ago
gets on kills he was living in his van
four to six months ago live in his van
four to six months ago gets on kill tony
becomes a regular on kill tony shows
incredible work ethic like we were
talking about before just putting in the
time and the effort who puts in the time
and effort more than hans nobody nobody
sometimes i'll look over my shoulder to
see what he's doing on his phone and
he's always on a spreadsheet
staring at jokes rewriting jokes taking
out a word adding a word it's a [ __ ]
animal he's not doing anything else no
[ __ ] yeah he's an animal yep and uh
murdering on stage he's coming for
everybody's jobs he's
he's there he's he's doing everything
that we talked earlier about which is
obsessing hours a day
being a crazy person and he loves it he
lives for it
i mean we had such a lineup last night
hans kim
doug stanhope roseanne barr
ron white you and me i mean it's the
show's
five assassins deep before i ever even
get on stage yeah that's a crazy lineup
amazing amazing that's a crazy lineup
anywhere i think we have the best crowds
yeah they're the best crowds they're so
fun they're so enthusiastic it's all
word of mouth hans kim always starts it
off crazy but that was insane
yeah well he's a great guy to get it
started off too because he's so
structured he gets you into a rhythm
very quickly where you're laughing set
up punchline set up punchline they're
all like really good
funny they're they're there's no fat in
his material economy of words excellent
it's just um
you know it's cool to see
comedy outside of any other system
just comedy by itself you know it's
commonly supported by just live comedy
like that's where it's at it's best it's
when it's connected to all those other
things like your potential to do other
shows or agents opinions or managers
opinions like